mit strom auf achse für den lastverkehr
auf der straße gibt es seit dienstag in
deutschland einen bundesweit
einzigartigen feldversuche in hessen
befahren oberleitung hybrid lastwagen
ein extra dafür ausgerüsteten test
abschnitt der autobahn a 5 zwischen
langen mörfelden und weiterstadt
aktuell könnten insgesamt zehn kilometer
elektrisch gefahren werden sagt der
präsident des betreibers hessen mobil
gerd riegelhuth der test soll zeigen ob
die technologie ausgebaut wird
es gibt studien die parallel dazu in
erstellt worden sind in der
vergangenheit schon die davon ausgehen
dass man wenn man in deutschland 30
prozent des autobahnnetzes damit
ausstatten würde etwa 80 prozent des
schwerverkehrs elektrische abgewickelt
werden könnte nach angaben der
hessischen straßenbaubehörde sind die
lkw sowohl mit einem elektro als auch
mit einem dieselmotor ausgestattet
ihre batterien ließen sich über
oberleitungen rasch aufladen solange das
fahrzeug also mit der oberleitung
verbunden ist nutzt es demzufolge sein
elektromotor und befüllt parallel seine
batterien der diesel motor springt ein
wenn die batterie leer ist
rita schwarzelühr-sutter
parlamentarische staatssekretärin im
bundesumweltministerium lobt das projekt
schauen sie wenn wir wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben wollen und wenn wir auch die
arbeitsplätze und das ist uns wichtig
hier in deutschland erhalten wollen dann
müssen wir in innovative
lösungen investieren und wenn tesla zum
beispiele an kündigt einen lkw auf den
markt zu bringen 40 tonner der 800 km
reichweite hat dann ist es hier gut
investiertes geld den bau der anlage hat
das bundesumweltministerium mit 14,6
millionen euro gefördert weitere 15,3
millionen euro stehen demnach für die
umsetzung des bis ende 2022 angesetzten
feldversuchs bereit
und wie fährt sich so ein lkw andreas
pettersson hat den brummi der nicht
brummt getestet diese stille das ist das
besondere das ist ein bauchgefühl wenn
man mit laufendem motor auf die autobahn
rollt und der die oberleitungen und den
stromabnehmer aus fährt wird der lärm
auf dann herrscht ruhe
bis auf den anderen verkehr natürlich
den kann man hören
[Musik]
laut der hessischen
straßenverkehrsbehörde soll die zahl der
oberleitung hybrid lkw bis mitte
nächsten jahres auf 5 anwachsen
sie sollen mehrmals täglich auf der
teststrecke unterwegs sein